do you think about her
you miss her
of course
i
keep my mother in my prayer every day
and the thing i pray the most
uh beyond giving thanks is
i pray that her name is honored and
remembered by my family
i don't know if the world's gonna
remember her right
even though if you watch my movie love
beats rhymes i named the school in that
movie
after my mother just
leave it somewhere else
in physical space yeah exactly but yeah
painful the pain of my mother's
passion
is indescribable only until it happens
to a person
they know and then they won't describe
it either only the people that lost
their mother they could look at each
other and they got this nod you know
what i mean
um but one other thing happened to me
was the joy of life hit me differently
and i think it was the realization
of my own
mortality versus my immortality
it's a big big thing and i don't know if
we'll get to expound on that but there
was a joy that overcame me because i was
kind of free of a certain illusion
about the immortality
of my physical being
versus the mortality of my physical
being
and i was like okay wow i understand so
that was the first or the hardest
realization you've experienced that
you're mortal
yeah that yeah and i'll say mortal
and the what you're looking at here
physically
i won't say my soul is mortal
right i'll say it's immortal because at
the end of the day
it's just like i could sit here
and i could just hum please please
please
by james brown
but james brown
is not gonna
come in here and do that
so in some sense james brown is still
here in another sense
so the soul is here
well it lives through you by you singing
it it lists through you by you listening
to it celebrating it
and the hope is that
the human species continues to celebrate
the the great minds and the great
creations of the past
i would add this to that equation
when i say it's immortal
i don't think not just only because
somebody sings it right
it's like why where's the fire at right
now
it's in the air
you just gotta spark this
yeah
so it's always there
you